i have some of the biggest youtubers in
a server with over 1 000 minecraft
players and these armies are going to
figure out which of their troops come
out on top in this giant world war the
leaders are technoblade fundy spyfee
carl chandler and philippe the war has
officially begun usa usa let's kill
chandler let's go fight chandler go go
go go go go chris is definitely coming
to get me so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna push into the desert we need
to take the high ground you're literally
surrounded by everyone you're in the
dead middle of the map you heard the man
fortify this area immediately oh that's
kind of cool so you're gonna mold the
pyramid into your own structure we have
to stand our ground here we're
surrounded already tag now what do you
think of the 200 random children on your
team i see seasoned warriors who will
easily win this challenge fundy how are
things going with your army i have a
beautiful plan mr beast whenever an
enemy approaches everyone just starts
pillaring up your strategy is to be a
coward i i don't think we have to
strength hey if you look at the map
chandler's getting pretty close to you
team get dirt more dart there's like
gold up there guys just get like iron
pickaxes and make like gold armor out of
that don't mind it with this did you
just mine it with a stone pickaxe get an
iron one it's over we're lost we've lost
i think we should hollow out this big
structure and this will be our home base
if everybody works together we can dig
this out very easily
whoa somebody's making a cactus barrier
that's genius
there's a bunch of gold blocks everyone
come this way what's this gold from we
ripped apart a local structure used our
own benefit let's try and rush carl and
try and surround all of his people it
looks like spiffy's heading down towards
carl oh we're so close they're up there
we will leave no man standing if we kill
coal we could potentially win this
wait they're invading they're invading
if i die we automatically lose so you
guys have to help me and protect me oh
wait we got a war going on in the south
quadrant oh my gosh
[Applause]
there's a war breaking out attack
anybody with the white name they're
going down oh wait is that call it's
called jacobs no i'm gonna die no run
away
oh the humanity use the cacti to your
advantage carl you're under fire i know
we're gonna kill them i'm not even
worried why did they attack you so early
i don't know they want to lose i guess
i died i died what the heck call died we
got it let's go you lost 122 warriors
you have 78 remaining
all right we're going to win this war
guys we got this we have an important
geological advantage we got two huge
oceans to our east and our west going to
be very difficult to actually invade us
can we build a shrine of technoblake and
then techno won't attack us does that
make sense that is not a good shrine
that's among us you built among us i
think we have a lot a lot of snow i
think we should go back and get more
gear we're gonna go to japan bundy's
running away from us he fears he fears
we gotta start killing people before
they ally against us everyone find
diamonds we need to work on getting our
guys geared up wait phil do you have a
pickaxe i don't
chris i didn't know he wasn't using a
pickaxe techno how are things going over
here in north america we're taking
advantage of the mines between me and
you i think you're gonna win it is time
to go to war men we're gonna go to war
we're gonna destroy felipe in south
america all right as techno prepared to
head towards south america and chandler
built his base things calmed down a bit
too much so i decided to tell fundy that
he needed to cause some trouble bundy i
think you should go down there for spfee
you have more than double the people
spifi has it is time to attack gentlemen
it is time to go hey we'll get on the
ground let's go let's go oh fondly's
coming wait false alarm false alarm
everyone to the top of the mountain go
go go this could be bad fundy has a big
big army it is time the island of
australia is approaching all right bundy
is on the cusp it is time
you're evading from the ocean oh boy
look at all these guys pouring in
gentlemen attack everyone who is not
greed and named no april get to the high
ground go go go you're down to 59
players how many how many of these fun
they got uh fundies literally lost like
one
oh oh dude this guy this guy on fundy's
team has full diamond attack them all
push people off funny of mercy never
i think i just killed someone
oh oh my god oh my god i just fell i
just fell oh no oh no no no push them
off get him
save me
no no no no no no no no i need more loot
oh my god why is money where's monday oh
god oh no no
i have looted the corpse of the spyfur
we need to get resources now be ready we
know how to win the game
later fundy
with fundy and spifey out the war is
down to techno philippe and chandler
this is gonna turn into an all-out
battle chandler's still alive right do
you think we should go after him now's
our time we gotta get up to the surface
now all right let's go attack chandler
now attention everyone chris is coming
here quickly team africa come on
everyone everyone up here now yo
chandler your fortress is looking insane
team africa is going to work let's go
kill oh wait techno's coming from behind
that knows coming from behind usa usa oh
techno who's going after chris no way oh
wow they're just swimming out of there
they're gone techno's coming for us uh
yo we just booted them out of their
whole continent they dipped we're going
to africa boys let's go
all right good for chandler chris is
entering in africa right now techno on
his tail we might have two teams on us
we want chandler's blood
taylor i'm coming for you
he's coming everyone prepare there they
are
oh they based they based there it is
they sky base they're weenies each other
they're attacking we can do this my
people murder him
africa kill phil all you guys move
forward
move
forward all right you have 135 people
that have 137 it's dead even all right
we can do this we can do this there he
is see the red wolf block get him oh i
see red take out the red team guys with
armor to the front we attack destroy
their flanks men take out everyone yeah
oh tacto's here oh whoa wait tactile's
coming in check no everyone retreat
knock knock it's the united states he's
probably inside this insane building
that they built i murder time they're
throwing lava
oh oh my god i just got hit
save me he's coming for me i'm gonna die
i die i i'm that what the heck just
happened the war is now down to techno
versus chandler and while techno has
more people chandler has a massive home
field advantage with his huge base this
will be interesting red is down yes yes
okay go for techno took one down i see
another one panda of titan take him down
if you see the leader just try and take
him out let's go
all right swim up the water infiltrate
they spotted us everyone get techno we
need him to die they're cj jailer oh
blue's coming up quickly storm the base
get em this is it everyone attack tech
note all right i'm going down to the
front lines let's go everyone jump down
five techno oh wait i'm getting
assassinated someone helped someone help
oh my gosh jayla's got it hot
why team africa why didn't we just storm
techno usa usa and all those other
countries but mostly usa we did it boys
grab their oil all right and with that
we're gonna end the video goodbye